against Gary Kasparov to become a world
champion and I had a job there
um I was 10 pounds an hour showing
people to those the chairs in The
Stadium
10 pounds an hour was great at 2 000.
yeah I was rolling in it and I could
watch the chess after I showed them to
the chairs and then they started playing
the Berlin like what the hell am I doing
here probably anywhere else it's a good
way to frustrate whites just to make
them it feels like banging your head
against the wall trying to break the
Berlin and
um I've had many kind of games when I've
had black and my opponents have just got
frustrated overpressed and it's a good
counter-attacking opening and okay hands
mean while pushing Pawns the okay really
nice way of retreating as a rook
offering a rook trade that's a brilliant
because now it's dark Square Bishop is
allowed to come in you know he's
breaking the pin and as Chucky resigned
Chucky has just resigned 17 minutes a
smile and he looks a little bit
surprised actually Hans name on but this
is a fantastic